we're here in freiburg tiny stadium now
set to see another season of Bundesliga
action with a very special personality
on the sidelines Christian Streich who's
managed the club for the past three
years the Freiburg coaches famous for
his emotional behavior he never tires of
saying how happy he is to be working
with his team the only problem is the
year after year his best players get
snapped up by the big clubs besides mr.
strategy is there a way out of this
vicious cycle of bringing up new players
and losing your best ones giving us an
employer or speed and Gibson ozbek yes a
first end is moon was it of course there
is we just have to play such good
football that we get into an economic
position that allows us to hang on to
our players last year we lost a lot of
players and a lot of the current ones
are attracting attention because they've
developed so well Maya's ah de las but
will be hanging on to more the food was
like that's a positive development and
why shouldn't we succeed econo does he'd
mishanti entwicklung when I'm solace is
nice killing women so i buy the material
of this week we work with young players
and all the other clubs know that a
sheltie movie attends disease and
players with serious advisers are being
told to go to freiburg nevada god in to
mystify books again if their advisers
are just interested in making a quick
buck they won't tell them to go to
freiburg look after clever they'll tell
them to come here because afterwards the
value of the players will increase the
outside dish below the amenity and young
spielen of potsdam you and your young
team has managed to stay the course
despite departures that's partly because
you push your players hard every week as
you say yourself what do you demand from
them what we see you long enough young
bit wolf I want them to focus on their
job and be able to take criticism I mean
positive criticism
they have to be able to take that on
board and learn its few positive okay
can not think they've already achieved
everything yet sabzi son you have to be
constantly willing to improve stand
again babe I chuffed 6 to focus on
lavish meal and we have players on our
squad [ __ ] model cream osh who have
developed enormously past year of the
promised land babalons 33 I think and
when you have players like him now Volvo
with such incredible openness I and a
willingness to take criticism then what
better role model can you have he
doesn't blame mistakes on the younger
players he just takes responsibility and
keeps trying to improve himself well you
yet you still need annually and schuster
and all the others gelsin Fernandez I'm
talking about the older players who have
more experience when someone like
Fernandez who's played for six different
teams says he's never seen anything like
the meticulous work we do with the young
players well in that respect we belong
to the elite in Germany little as I like
that word in deutschland indecent poot
stream does Octus is it true that you
want your players to not focus only on
football but to have other interests too
and with your uncle and cousin and
bigger just coming if the fish demon you
can't influence them to some people get
a lot out of football but while others
get their energy from other things those
are individual differences against
individual window shield always keep you
long but there are players who play
football all the time on their
Playstations because they love it in my
food spot or maybe they throw a
basketball around up those guns feeling
yeah and they get a lot of energy from
it that's up to them I'm not the person
to say read a book or do this or that
it's a matter of individual freedom
house diesel is but one person will get
one thing from that freedom another from
something different ladies if I I die so
we give them their freedom but we also
want to see them developing
professionally and personally inside a
big wolf we're inside a passer una
sprite and we demand that of that but it
also goes for us no matter how old we
are
a godly I listened balsa where do you
get it from not to my schpeel hasta you
run the players for example I get to
work with these young people who are
also different as individuals individual
house people and I get it from a lot of
different things but mainly football
because I do spend a lot of time with by
alastair feeler be chef deep in the mid
yeah I work intensively with football
every day don't you sometimes wish you
have more time for other things Venice
exit Isaac yesterday had 36 hours i
might get around to other things under
thought about I get then there'd be
fewer days nice i'm i see but let's say
7 36 hour days but then we do a little
more here and a little more there and
that the hours would be gone now that
the season's ending we have a couple of
weeks to take care of other things then
I'm up have all home loans but it's a
privilege to be able to do that and as
you shower a preemie Lake this market to
do other from smooth canvas finally I'd
like to ask where are you headed with
freiburg what's your goal not just in
terms of the league but in terms of
development yeah not so good the best
possible football for the spectators so
they'll continue to enjoy continuity and
that the fans keep coming to see these
great young players and great matches
great magical EDM that's basically the
most important thing for me polish
feeling this is I need this was young a
mystic stage